I have just started seeing someone who
has a thing for a cockney accent how can
I nail a cockney accent what tips do you
have for being a cracking cockney in
everyday life can I warn you against me
I think there's try don't try no I think
just drop this one yeah yeah give him a
little tap on the bottom with your
umbrella walk about to glammo of me
joshing house and today we are joined by
the living legend that is lin-manuel
Miranda I'm joined by the all-singing
all-dancing babes for Mary Poppins
better than Emily no we're gonna play a
game with you called be more merry in
the spirit of be more Beyonce well I'm
gonna give you some problems it's five
by the film and you're gonna give me
some advice you are the expert in the
cockney accent when it comes to Mary
Poppins returns what tips can give me
for nailing the cockney accent and
living that cockney life and I wasn't
listening to contemporary hip hop to
prepare for this movie I was listening
to the music hall songs from the 1930s I
am the very model of a modern
major-general understand matters
vegetable animal and mineral if I was
gonna hit the Christmas party this
season I want to get bit more Mary
Poppins on my dance moves yeah
what would you recommend you get a good
lamppost swing is hard they do that kind
of great dance thing with Meryl Streep's
character tops and they sort of do yes
that thing with their feet on this if
you can do it on the ceiling
well yeah would obviously be really good
it means to turn the post up upside down
yeah Graham and that gives the right
like you still get the lights my
wardrobe and betta routine has become a
bit run-of-the-mill what top ticks can
you give me for being spit-spot and
practically perfect in every single way
clean fingernails I think I got tip
right what do you do you but you're
looking at your bits pressed by my
manicure no I've been impressed about my
own fingers which I never do you do
clean them what's your guy's surface
bits bullets you [ __ ] up she's your net
babe best pickup lines deploy Mary
Poppins style I should probably ask Dick
Van Dyke I think he was a lot more
flirtatious with her what is jolly
holiday 21 long flirt between Mary and
Bert what top tips you give me what I'm
feeling
lie
self-esteem to get myself out of that
love with young people I think dancing
actually yes dancing and singing it
always happens with Disney films where
there's a discussion about loss and you
know like lying can be getting a Bambi
you just can't believe it you're just
like I'm a kid I shouldn't have to be
dealing with this kind of stuff like
this is too much no it's always the mom
isn't it always the mom whereas it was
the mothers never the dads
Oh Simba's dad died oh that's just true
in brave is the doctor is that dead
anyway it's brave Eve in the Disney film